le déconfinement va dépendre dans sa
réalisation d'éléments dont nous ne
disposons pas aujourd'hui entièrement
quelles sont ces éléments d'abord on
sent bien que le déconfinement sera
différent différence il existe au moment
du des confirmands des traitements et
prouver ou s'il n'en existe pas que la
réponse apportée à la question du
déconfinement pourra dépendre aussi de
notre capacité et je suis sûr que nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir à tester
et à tester quoi et attester qu'ils car
lorsqu'on parle des tests encore faut-il
savoir de quels tests l'ont pas et de
quelles capacités
on a à produire ces tests et à les
réaliser dans de bonnes conditions
7ce déconfinement dépendra aussi et je
parle sous le contrôle d'olivier ferrand
qui est médecin lui ce que je ne suis
pas et ce que je ne prétends pas être
dépendra aussi de la façon dont le virus
aura circuler et donc de la proportion
de nos concitoyens qui ayant été en
contact avec le virus et ayant développé
des anticorps qui leur permettre qui
leur permettent d'avoir une une
immunisation immunité jeu pas comment il
faut dire une immunisation une
immunisation combien quelle proportion
de françaises et de français vont
pouvoir disposer de cette immunisation
et donc comment le virus va recommencer
ou pourrait recommencer à circuler ce
qui est à peu près acquis à ce stade
c'est que nous avons décidé du
confinement en application d'une
stratégie que le ministre et moi-même
avons plusieurs fois expliqué qui
consiste à limiter le nombre de cas
sévères en essayant de faire en sorte
qu'ils ne dépassent pas les places
disponibles d'accueil dans les services
de soins intensifs et réanimation
cet indicateur aussi longtemps qu'il n'y
a pas de traitement prouver pas de
vaccin reste évidemment un indicateur
décisif pour le déconfinement il est
donc probable jeudi probable et j'essaie
d'être précis dans mes mots probable que
nous ne nous acheminons pas vers un
déconfinement qui serait générale et
absolue en une fois partout et pour tout
le monde
encore une fois je dis c'est probable
nous avons nous demandé à plusieurs
équipes de travailler sur cette question
du déconfinement en étudiants
l'opportunité la faisabilité d'un
déconfinement qui serait régionaliser
oudin déconfinement qui serait sujet à
une politique de test et si oui laquelle
ou un déconfinement qui serait en
fonction qui sait de classe d'âge bref
nous sommes en train de travailler et
d'expertisé des scénarios en fonction
des hypothèses
ce que je crois utile de rappeler c'est
que d'abord la discussion sur ce
déconfinement devra avoir lieu
c'est une stratégie nationale qui devra
être discutée présentés et discutés et
elle le sera
elle devra prendre en compte avant tout
des impératifs de santé de protection de
la santé et nous espérons et là encore
je suis prudent dans les mots que
j'utilise
nous espérons pouvoir avancer sur le
sujet et présenter des éléments d'une
stratégie de déconfinement dans les
jours et semaines qui viennent de façon
la semaine les jours qui viennent de
façon à pouvoir exposer et donner une
perspective à nos concitoyens